if you only reward the winning then you
stay small for Life the more that you
reward the effort and then you keep
going you will get the results do
results matter of course but how do you
get the momentum to keep getting the
results well you have to have the
encouragement the courage and the
permission to start and the people who
succeed the most have failed the most
we're so afraid to fail that we don't
even try I think your business value
will come from the results that you're
getting your self-worth value comes from
the effort that you're putting in if you
only do things where you know you're
going to win you place them off for life
and you end up hating your life cuz now
you're just inside your comfort zone
doing all the stuff that you know you
can win